a warm-up on a cold morning for these
children some of the poorest of the poor
living on the outskirts of the national
capital
[Music]
excitement as their school pulls up
[Music]
the whole bus is their classroom for a
few hours every morning
it's probably the only opportunity these
children have out here for any learning
[Music]
teachers and volunteers of tejas asia a
non-profit group have been working for
the underprivileged for years
[Music]
in all this fun and chatter there is the
serious fundamental introduction of a
formal education
which otherwise would be lacking
the pandemic has made matters worse as
schools remain shut and restricted
they switched to online classes but for
the children living on the periphery
it's a dream
it has been a difficult season for the
for the families for the children
it it's very depressing to see that but
whenever we go with the team you know we
play songs with them uh we uh uh show
the television on the telly on the on
the bus
we get them involved in different team
activities and we can see hope rising in
many of the communities
[Applause]
every day four such buses fan out to the
most marginalized communities living on
the edge
after classes they line up for a hot
meal of rice and chickpea curry
[Music]
this nourishing free lunch is an added
attraction
scores of families live here on meager
earnings collecting and recycling
rubbish
their children could easily fall through
the cracks of gaining any formal
education
homes are temporary and vulnerable to
the elements
there is no clean drinking water medical
facility and electricity is scarce
eleven-year-old preethi shares this one
room shack with five siblings and
parents
she wants to be a teacher and doesn't
miss a day of class
for this brief period in their otherwise
hard day the children find their escape
this classroom takes them away from
their struggle and wretchedness of their
daily lives
neville lazarus sky news into
delhi